All right, let's get into audience questions
for the week, one that I've been getting from
people all over the world with anecdotes and
also from Americans asking what is going on
elsewhere in the world is what is the reaction
around the world to Donald Trump's refusal
to accept that he simply lost his continued
promotion of these completely baseless factness
conspiracy theories about voter fraud and
massive dumps, as he talked about over the
weekend, and that he really won Georgia and
he really won Pennsylvania and so on.
How does the world see it?
And the answer is that much of the world is
laughing.
But a lot of the world is also really concerned
by by what they are seeing.
And of course, the question spot on that it's
been a month.
There's been no real concession from Trump
where he says, I got I got beat.
I was defeated.
Joe Biden got more votes in more states.
Donald Trump has sort of danced around it.
He's authorized the transition to start.
And we'll talk about that transition a little
bit later in the segment.
He has sort of almost had some verbal slip
ups where he says, you know, we won't do a
shutdown.
I don't know if the next I mean, I can't speak
for anybody else, but we won't do a shutdown.
Right.
That we've seen that stuff and we've even
seen reports of Trump privately understanding
that he doesn't have a path to victory.
But there's been no real concession from Donald
Trump.
A lot of the world is laughing and tends to
see Trump more as just an idiot.
And that includes, like, anecdotally, the
people I hear from who watch the show, who
are in Ireland, just like as one example,
they are more on the we can't believe this
idiotic moron and the things that he is doing
anecdotally.
Again, our viewers from Germany, they don't
seem to be finding the humor in it as much
as some others, and they seem genuinely worried
about the state of our democracy.
Now, maybe that's something about Germany's
past that informs how the Germans I'm hearing
from are reacting differently to the Irish
folks that I'm hearing from.
But when the world sees that world leaders
are calling Biden, they're talking about getting
things done with Joe Biden.
They're getting started on a variety of projects
and issues.
It's Biden that world leaders are now dealing
with when it comes to coronavirus.
As an example, Joe Biden's task force already
seemingly more ready and willing to get things
done than the one that Donald Trump has had
in place for more than half a year at this
point in time.
And so while there is some laughter and some
pointing and some look at that idiot in the
United States, there is also the doubt that
the world is increasingly experiencing about
like what is the standing of the United States
in terms of a democracy?
What is going on with the strength of American
checks and balances that this continues to
go on?
And then if you're paying attention to the
legal maneuvers that the Trump legal team
is trying, it's the stuff of shame, not putting
in the legal briefs, the things they say publicly,
like there was actual fraud.
They don't put that in the legal briefs because
they know they don't have the evidence for
it.
And earlier this week, we had this clip of
news anchors from Brazil unable to contain
their laughter at Donald Trump's bizarre press
conference on Thanksgiving Day.
There's also a lot of straight up pointing
and laughing.
There's no there's certainly no shortage of
it.
We are increasingly seen as an unstable country,
one that cannot be trusted in deals.
The Iran deal being the perfect example.
Any foreign deal made with one president could
be thrown out by the next president, as Donald
Trump did with the Iran deal, even though
Iran didn't actually violate any aspects of
that deal.
So this is you know, the big picture is whether
you're laughing or crying or scared or whatever
your view is of what's going on.
Embarrassed for the United States.
The big picture is how can such a rich country
considered to be the leader on so many issues
until only a short time ago?
How can we be having these problems?
How can we be having a president who can't
even tell the truth for a minute when the
topic of whether he lost comes up?
How do we have so many people without health
care and people on food stamps and people
lacking basic education and crumbling infrastructure?
Laughable airports consider to other rich
countries like the problems are, of course,
bigger than Donald Trump.
How do we have this religious nut antiscience
thing running rampant, even not just people,
but people in positions of power in the United
States?
Some of this stuff, Joe Biden can start to
write, some of it takes much longer and it's
much more than just a president can do.
And it goes well beyond the Oval Office and.
So we've really got our work cut out for us
and the world is noticing now a lot of Trump
don't care.
A lot of Trump is, say, white sissy.
Europeans don't like what we're doing.
It must mean we're doing the right thing.
I mean, that's the approach that a lot of
these Trump ists have, and that's part of
what we need to fix here.